Now, let's talk about scales for categorical data. A
categorical scale provides visual separation for different groups. And it
often works in tandem with a numerical scale, as
we'll see here when we plot home runs on the
y-axis. A bar plot, for example, can use a
categorical scale on the x-axis, and a numerical scale on
the y-axis. So let's say that we were measuring home
runs by position. The positions we've used here are unordered,
but you can imagine that if we have ordinal
data, we'd want these categories represented in the order that
the ordinal data suggests. That will make it easier to
compare and contrast your bars, or whatever encoding that you've
chosen to represent your data. Finally, let's talk about
time series data. The thing is, we can measure time
with various different granularities. So we could use months or
days or years on this x-axis, which will let us
visualize our data in a discreet way. Depending
on what you're trying to communicate with your data
You might use a different time scale here.
So, if you're looking at fluctuations that happen on
a very short time scale, days are more
appropriate, but if we're looking at long term trends,
we may want to look at data on a month to month or year to year basis.